s'allier pour mieux régner voilà la
ligne de conduite de ce second tour des
élections municipales et tous les coups
sont permis pour pouvoir accéder au
trône mais dans les 34 1968 communes
françaises le son de cloche n'est pas le
même partout
un marcheur peut s'allier avec un
républicain dans une ville tandis que
dans l'autre on préféra discuter avec
les verts autour d'une table et bannir
les républicains une configuration qui
crève les yeux
a lille par exemple socialistes et
écologistes lillois vont s'affronter
dans une triangulaire avec la république
en marche dans une configuration assez
inédite
les résultats du premier tour donne 29
8% pour madame aubry et 24 53 % pour
monsieur ben ali arrivé deuxième devant
la candidate la république en marche
violette est ce qu'il vous tu essaies et
17,50 3% si la gauche avait cumulé ces
scores la victoire était acquise et
depuis 1977 écologistes et socialistes
dirigent cet ensemble
la ville de lille mais les tensions dans
la majorité n'ont jamais cessé durant le
troisième mandat est de mère de madame
aubry et le divorce était inévitable
on a constaté à regret qu'il n'y avait
pas d' envie de communiquer avec nous
ils n'ont pas montré dans vie de faire
un accord dès le premier soir du premier
tour martine aubry n'est pas en colère
mais elle regrette et elle prend acte
pour les verts la seule responsable de
cette rupture et la maire ps
il y dénonce une campagne électorale
abrupt de la part de martine aubry
elle qui voulait garder le contrôle
absolu et sans partage il déplore
également un manque d'intérêt pour leurs
propositions à des tensions qui pourront
bien faire le jeu des marcheurs et de la
liste de violette espil boot
elle avait d'ailleurs proposé un
rapprochement à stéphane baly qui n'a
pas souhaité donner suite
un schéma quasi semblable à toulouse
mais cette fois la candidate des partis
de gauche
nadia pellefigue arrivé 3e retire
carrément sa candidature elle refuse de
s'allier à la liste des verts archipel
citoyens conduite par antoine maurice
arrivé second lors du premier tour
les échanges qui se sont tenues depuis
dix sud connaît tous permettent donc pas
de considérer que les conditions sont
aujourd'hui revenus réunis pour un
rassemblement de nos deux listes que
chacun porterai avec fierté et
enthousiasme
même si elle indique ne pas vouloir être
un obstacle au rassemblement à gauche
cette déclaration va profiter au maire
sortant et l'air à jean luc moudenc
arrivé en tête au premier tour
socialistes et écologistes sont donc en
désaccord à lille et à toulouse mais à
paris en revanche est pas la même
histoire il n'y a pas encore de fumée
blanche
mais on prépare le foyer j'ai bon espoir
que l'on top dès ce soir
oui les négociations vont bon train
david belliard le candidat e élevé est
confiant également et même si on achoppe
toujours sur des sujets de fond selon as
les mots de son entourage est la fusion
devrait bien et se tenir un soutien de
poids puisque le candidat écologiste a
récolté 10,8 pour cent des voix au
premier tour et qui pourrait bien faire
la différence
pour anne hidalgo un choix s'inscrivant
dans la durée les écologistes font en
effet partie de la majorité de gauche à
l'hôtel de ville de paris depuis 2001 et
l'élection de bertrand delanoë aliot
aussi on opte pour la sécurité après le
séisme provoqué par gérard collomb et
son alliance avec le candidat ait l'air
renault perd candidat de la gauche unie
à la métropole a confirmé qu'une
alliance avait été trouvé entre
l'ensemble de la gauche et les
écologistes
c'est fait nous allons nous présenter
ensemble pour le second tour derrière la
candidature de bruno bernard il y aura
la gauche unie la gauche rassemblée et
nous pourrons proposer aux habitants de
la métropole un vrai projet fondé sur
l'écologie et la justice sociale une
alliance qui devrait permettre aux
écologistes de réaliser le grand chelem
avec leur tandem grégory doucet à la
ville et bruno bernard à la métropole
pour marseille la situation est plus
complexe
mais là aussi l'enjeu pour le printemps
marseillais le parti de gauche arrivé en
tête était de parachever un accord avec
les écologistes afin de faire basculer
la ville gérée par la droite depuis plus
de 25 ans vous l'aurez compris dans la
plupart des grandes villes alliance
entre verts et gauche et au centre des
débats
pour ce second tour des élections
municipales mais les égos de chacun ont
tendance à prédominer quitte à bafouer
idéologie politique de leur part
si au profit même leurs aînés